okay hello everyone welcome to the
lecture today and today I prepare to
show you one of my games I played this
few years ago and my opponent is
Grandmaster shovel off it was a u.s.
champion four times and I played the
opening that I know the most I play this
opening for 24 years
it's a French defense and so I will show
you this game and explain you some of
the opening ideas and at the end I want
to do also some endgame positions today
with you so but first we'll go with this
game I played this game in 2003 so
almost 10 years ago and sociable of
played efore and I played a 6 so if
you're not familiar with the opening as
soon as you play it 6 the name of the
opening is French defense it's one of
the most popular defenses against efore
I would say e 4 there are probably three
different defenses e45 it's probably the
most popular another one would be the
Sicilian defense and I think the next
will be the French defense so my
opponent play d4 d5 and I played a 5
anybody familiar with this variation
that is playing what's the name of this
variation of the French defense ok let's
call advanced variation there are four
different lines white can play in this
position so here if he plays a 5 this
will be the advanced variation if it
takes on d5 this will be exchange if he
plays Knight d2 tie rush named after a
very strong chess player Zig Berto rush
and the next one is 93 the classical
variation nowadays if I play the French
I expect most people to play the 93
classical or to go to 92 line to rush
but in this game Grandmaster shovel off
played ePHI and he actually likes to
play this so when I'm playing he and
same I kind of expect that he's going to
play the advanced line because he likes
to play this move against the French
idea behind d5 is it's a very strong
pawn here it's actually controlling d6 +
f6 square and makes it very difficult
for me to develop develop the knight on
f6 that's why I have to play c5
immediately and put as much pressure as
possible on the default pawn because he
moved his pawn twice basically he lost
the tempo in the opening in fact he
gained some space but he lost some time
so that's why I have to play very active
and tried to put as much pressure as
possible on the d4 square on the pawn so
he plays c3
now I developed my knight actually I
start off with I played Queen b6 first
it's a transposition putting pressure on
d4 and also at the same time attacking
the pawn on b2 so now if you just
decided to defend the pawn with Bishop
e3 it's going to be very bad because I
can just simply capture the pawn even
though it's not a good idea in the
opening to develop the Queen too early
according to the principles but there
are some exceptions and this this
position is one of them so you develop
the Queen a little bit early but it's
okay in this position now
he played Knight f3 and a plate Bishop
d7 the worst minor piece in this opening
is the light square bishop for black an
idea behind this move is that I would
like to play in some point we should be
5 and exchange this that pace in general
it's it's good for you to know that the
worst piece is the light square bishop
so whenever you have a chance if you're
playing the French defense as black you
want to exchange this bishop for a
bishop or even for a night it will be
very good for you to exchange this
bishop so that's why that's why I'm
playing the Bishop d7 here trying to
play Bishop e5 yes
yeah absolutely because if it doesn't
place c3 in this position I will simply
capture the pawn on d4 next move and
then his ePHI pawn since this pawn is
advanced it's not going to have a
defense this will be very difficult for
it to defend so that's why yeah I can go
96 after that and the pawn will be weak
so that's why I basically he plays c3 to
protect the chain basically the e5 pawn
so I play Queen b6 Knight f3 Bishop d7
now my opponent played Bishop d3
developing his LightSquared Bishop and
preparing to castle before I play Bishop
b5 in this position I first exchange on
d4 and I was expecting him to take back
with a pawn because looks like this
would be the logical respond after
playing c3 but in fact he played Knight
takes d4 because he realized that I'm
trying to play Bishop e5 but now I
cannot play Bishop b5 because now he's
controlling the squirrel with his knight
and a bishop so he is playing against my
ideal Bishop b5 he wants to do
everything he can to prevent me from
exchanging the bishops very interesting
actually because if he takes back with a
pawn then I will play Bishop b5 as
unmeant as I mentioned to exchange the
bishops if it doesn't exchange if he
goes back to c2 after 96 actually is
going to be in trouble because now his
King will be stuck in the middle of the
board because he cannot cancel so black
will be better in this position and if
it takes I can just take back and again
luck is fine here so he played nine
takes d4 now it's going to be very
difficult for me to play Bishop b5
because he's controlling that square but
now after he take would you do put the
knight now is if I upon us a little bit
weak
so I played 96 developing my knight and
immediately attacking the pawn on e5
so he doesn't have much choice in this
position because if he just cancels it's
going to be very bad for him I just take
this central pawn so you can lose the
pawn so he played Knight takes c6 and
now I have a question for you here I
want you to spend maybe minute or two
anything and you can raise your hand and
I want to ask you if you were playing
this position with the black pieces how
are you going to recapture the knight
here because you have three different
ways you can capture this night with a
pawn with a bishop or with the Queen
what do you think is the best move here
for black excellent you don't want to
take with the Queen yeah very good
definitely Queen is out we don't even
want to consider that but it's not easy
because you know you both move seems
like I mean they're both playable in
fact but what do you think is the best
move yes
try to trade off that vision it also
gets your Bishop out from behind upon
chain
route it down well it's interesting
but but that the problem would take it
with the bishop is he will play Queenie
- he knows the threat so he's going to
develop his queen and again prevent me
from playing Bishop b5 because he's got
now two pieces attacking on it and
another thing here in the future his
knight is going to have an excellent
square to go to on d4 so it will be a
very good outpost for his knight to go
on before and I don't have a pawn on c5
to move this Knight
so that's why I decided to take with a
pawn in this game you can't take with a
bishop but better is to take with a pawn
yes absolutely I could use the B file
yes I could use the B file later on also
to put some pressure on the b2 pawn but
the most important thing I want to play
c5 and then I will control a lot of the
central squares and still I'm going to
have the opportunity to play Bishop b5
in general in the opening at the early
stage of the opening it's a good idea to
try to capture with a pawn towards the
center okay you want to capture and get
control as many central squares as you
can so that's why I took with a pawn now
he cancelled and now I play this move f5
who can tell me what's the idea behind
this move because I talk about playing
c5 and suddenly I kind of shifted them
played f5 here but what do you see
what's the idea behind this move
I'm trying to control but there is
something else I'm trying to do here if
you look at the position which minor
piece is the most active piece for white
that he can try to use potentially to
attack Bishop Bishop on d3 right this is
his best minor piece here very active so
that's why I want to play f5 and now I
basically I give him a choice either he
can take on Poisson but then he's not
going to have the strong pawn here
controlling the f6 and the six square or
he's going to allow me to have a pot on
f5 which will shut down the bishop for
the rest of the game and he's not going
to be able to threaten any attacking
ideas along that diagonal so with the
pawn on f5 the bishop on d3 it's not as
strong anymore so let's take a look if
he takes on Poisson if he takes on pass
on by the way everybody familiar with
the UM poisson rule yes absolutely so
i'm poisson basically i'm poisson only
works if one player advances the pawn
two squares from the original position
so once you place this move you can just
capture the pawn here it's like he
played this move once same thing if you
place this move you can just take the
idea is basically this pawn is guarding
the square the square so when you
advance the pawn to two squares you
can't really pass it that's why he can
take that's done Poisson now if it takes
this in fact I think black is already
better because after I take Knight f6
next move will be Bishop d6 follow it up
with castle and n e5 and I think I have
a very strong center and my rook on f8
also going to be developed which will
give me some lead in development as well
and a very strong position for black and
at the meantime as you can see all these
pieces on the Queen side not develop yet
and I will have the control of the
center so that's why I was of course
hoping he would take but I knew that you
know it's not really likely he's going
to take on Poisson so he played see for
now he's putting pressure on d5 if he
didn't play this move for example he
would play it like Knight d2 just a
developing move then I can simply play
c5 and I have now I really have the
control of most most of the squares here
and now I'm already worried about the
Queen chick because I will just play g6
and now white will have to move the
Queen again it doesn't really accomplish
that much I mean it may seem like it's
weakening a little bit but in fact it's
not it's not weakening that much the
temples are more important in this
position than just this idea some some
positions you can play this but this
position is kind of closed so that's why
it's not really too much so the reason
he played c4 now because I cannot play
c5 because this will be very dangerous
because he will take and my Center will
be very weak now see my d5 pawn is weak
so that's why I cannot play c5 now so I
played 97 developing my knight Knight c3
Knight is going to g6 now putting
pressure on e5 pawn now I would like to
develop my Bishop and Castle after I do
that I have a very nice position here I
might be actually slightly better here
the B file is very important actually
because in this position I cook my queen
is already putting pressure on between
also I could use the rook b8 idea
remember if you see in 1/2 1/2 open file
or open file you always want to put a
rock on that file in this position this
is a half-open file because there is a
panel b2 if white didn't have a pawn on
b2 this would have been an open file
and now my opponent played Bishop III
attacking on the Queen
now like to play can you find the best
move in this position he didn't blunder
a piece it may seems like I can just
play d4 right and it will be a four but
he didn't blunder there is something
behind it
well if you capture the b-pawn usually
when your king is in the middle of the
board and you're behind in development
it's very risky to capture a pond
because that will further delay the
development it's like a general rule and
in this position white is very well
developed already here so I'm kind of
behind in development so I wouldn't want
to take this pawn even if there is
something I'm not losing or anything
immediately it's just very risky because
I should think about just developing
these pieces and castle but also I don't
I don't want to just move my Queen
because then I just lose a temple can i
play Bishop c5 aha get four cow Bishop
c5 loses yeah you should you should know
this move if you play Bishop c5 then you
always have to look for this move Knight
a4 working the Queen and a bishop and
now I'm losing a piece we have to be
very careful you have to always have to
look even though we know the Knights
they're not strong on the side of the
board but sometimes there are some
strong moves like this and now I will
lose a piece so I cannot play Bishop c5
what else I can do here
well if you play a policy five the
problem with this move is he just takes
and then now my Center is very loose and
I will add on losing upon actually so I
don't want to play c5 yet what about the
most natural move here did you look at
that move when you see two pieces like
this right what's the first move you
have to look before right because you're
forking two pieces when you tacking two
pieces at the same time that's a fork
now he plays Knight a4 and looks like I
have to move my queen and he's going to
capture on default because if I just
move my Queen away he's going to capture
but I have a very nice move here in fact
it's it's it's like a small combination
here what can I do here
well queen is hanging this part I can't
take Knight is protected so Queen before
you're close you're very close but you
have something even better than that
because when you go Queen before he's
going to go Bishop d2 attacking your
queen there's a better Square for the
Queen to go to Queen if I but do you see
what's the idea behind it if you play
Queen eighty-five and if he takes the
pawn so Queen a5 that's right but now if
he takes the pawn this move losses
actually for him do you see what I can
do well I can take yet because Queen is
protecting it ah hi you push the pawn to
c5 first and now he loses a piece
because now I'm attacking two pieces at
the same time so it's a little practical
idea if I don't have this idea I would
just lose upon then B I couldn't play d4
so it's very important that I have this
move c5 because this really changes the
evaluation of the position now black is
better if I didn't have this I will be
just worse because I would have to move
my Queen back again like imagine if I
didn't have d4 here I have to move my
Queen back and then I'm still not
developed and my King is in the middle
of the board so Queen a5 now he cannot
take again let's take a look again why
c5 now attacking the bishop and the
night at the same time and now he loses
a piece so he played Bishop d2 attacking
my queen and now what's the best move
you always have to look at the whole
board right
absolutely now that's the difference why
I want to go Queen a5 then not Queen
before for exampie cuz now I can take
the pawn on e5 with the Queen I'm up a
pawn but it's not so easy because now he
still has the lead in development but
this ePHI pawn is very important because
if I can consolidate my position finish
my development then I have a very strong
center but now he's going to get some
temples rook e1 attacking on the Queen
when he makes a move attacking your
piece he wins the temple and temples are
very important in chess sometimes you
could be up material but if you lose a
lot of temples you could be in trouble
so here I have to be very careful
I go Queen f6 now I would like to play
c5 in this position to strengthen the d4
pawn and open the diagonal for my bishop
but of course he plays them off first
now he stops me from playing c5 we
should be seven developing if I can just
castle now I will have a very nice
position but he plays now Queen b3 and
now if I Castle he has a very unpleasant
move Queen b7 attacking activating his
queen attacking on the bishop and
strangely enough I don't have a good way
to defend this piece because if I try to
defend it with the rook for example he
plays Bishop a5 so I cannot do that and
also this bishop is important because
protects the c6 pawn so I cannot castle
because after Queen b7 and I be in
trouble here the reason also I choose
this game to show you because the next
couple of moves are going to be very
unusual and you probably haven't seen
that many games when one player develops
his pieces first and
he brings the pieces back so it's here
very important for me to stop him from
playing queen bee 7 and I have only one
way can only one way to stop him from
doing that how can you stop him from
playing queen bee 7
absolutely
now I bring the bishop back now he
cannot enter to be 7f 4 good move again
now he fixed my pawn only 6 because I
was thinking of advancing it but now I
can because now he is controlling this
square and I cannot open the position
here because my king is in the middle of
the board now my bishop only 7 is very
passive now I bring the other bishop to
d8 now most of my pieces on the last
Frankish but now I'm planning to
activate this bishop by putting into c7
Bishop c4 now he's increasing the
pressure only 6 now he has three pieces
attacking rook Bishop and Queen
I play King f7c I didn't even castle in
this game because I need to protect this
pawn nine place rookie two is trying to
double up his looks on the e-file I play
rook e8 and now he played the rook a e1
if you look at this position it looks
like white should be better even though
he's down upon because he's got so much
pressure on e6 and my piece are passive
here and it's not so clear how I can
untangle here but first I play Bishop c7
activating the dark square Bishop Bishop
was very passive only seven couple of
months ago so by doing this maneuver
Bishop d8 Bishop c7 now I activated my
bishop and also now I'm preparing this
ePHI break here but first now he needs
to protect a four-pound because I have
two pieces attacking on so he brings the
Queen to f3 protecting and also
attacking on c6 I play Bishop d7
my place before now if I allow him this
night has misplaced for him if I allow
him to play night be to 93 then wife
will be better here
so if I place some slow moves try to go
King g8 King h8 just for safety of my
king he will put this night on d3 and
then he will continue with a 4 B 5 ideas
and every piece he has will be very nice
nicely placed so this night is misplaced
here and I have to play very
energetically here because if I don't
play a 5 here I will be in trouble so
what can you do here so you can play e5
because you can play right away because
the bishop is pinning
yes night we're on d5 well if I go 1960
in 97 he might even capture any six
because I blacked my rock I have to be
very quick here as I mentioned if he
plays Knight B 293 it would be very
difficult for me to play five
if I manage to play attack his Bishop
how which move a five
attacking this side no can't do that yet
try to try to play e5 you need to make
one strong move and then play e5 when
you play five all your pieces will be
very well placed now all the bishops
will be open the knight all the pieces
will come into the game absolutely
pink f8 I don't have time to go King g8
King h8 to play safe because he will
have time to put this knight on d3 now
I'm ready to play e5 he realizes I'm
threatening to play e5 right away and
then I will have a very nice position
because this is my backward pawn I will
get rid of this pawn and then I will
threaten to play also e4
then I'll have to protected past bounds
so he played b5 advancing this pawn and
now II five I also protect the c6
punished with my queen so it's a very
good timing to play e5 because he was
trying to take the pawn on c6 but after
I did this now if he captures on c6 I
can just simply play Bishop c6 and White
is in big trouble
Queen is hanging Knight is hanging this
piece is really misplaced here now let's
say he will go here and just push when
you have to protected passed pawns like
this in the middle of the board this is
just winning you cannot do anything now
so he didn't allow me this so he played
now he's in trouble
the reason v5 is very strong because
simple capture like F takes e5 loses to
Knight takes e5 because my knight now
comes in into the game and now with the
temple attacking the Queen and a bishop
that's why I was really trying to play
this move e5 because I realize once I
play e5 I might be just winning
so he's in big trouble now so he played
b6 attacking my bishop now what you want
to do now here we have a chance to get
attack the Queen absolutely
now you have very strong past bonds now
also his rooks are now ineffective
because before they were putting
pressure on this week pawn they were
constantly threatening to take but after
I play e5 e4 he's not going to take the
pawn it's not going to lose a rock for
two pounds so now he has to move his
queen and now I also played this move
with the tempo again to move his Queen
away he plays Queen h5 now I have to do
something here my bishop is hanging I
capture and now I'm also attacking his
Knight so now he brings his knight into
the game very strong now night now night
is very strong because it's putting
pressure on the bishop on a rook
so I simply took and he has a pawn to
strong panel b6 and now when opponent
has two bishops usually it's a good idea
to exchange one of the bishops because
it's an advantage to have a to bishops
in particular disposition now he is
threatening very strong move Bishop
before check and my King is in trouble
and if you remember I mentioned the
worst minor piece for black in this
opening is light square bishop right so
that's why I play there should be six
eight exchanging the strong bishop he
has and also again get rid of my worst
piece
he takes I take back with rook
and now he pushes his spawn a for he
also has some dangerous pawns on the
queenside but my pants are stronger
first I went King g8 to protect he
pushed a five and now I go if I the
differences I have three paths paths and
he has only two and usually when the
paths are in the center there is
stronger because they control more
squares and after I place c5 now my
pieces are putting some pressure on b6
so he can really push these pants now
and now I'm planning to play c4 c3 d3
and basically run down
so he goes rook c1 putting pressure on
c5 pawn now III not only am attacking on
the bishop I'm also threatening now to
capture on f4 because the bishop on d2
was protecting it but after this move if
it moves the bishop I can just simply
capture on a4 forking the Queen and the
rook so he can't just move the bishop
because he will just lose immediately
now for attacking the Queen again this
is a fork when you're attacking two
pieces at the same time it's a fork now
you take only two now I'm up exchange so
this is just losing right away so nine
please Queen f3 you have to be carefull
see it leaves this bishop hanging but he
plays Queen f3 threatening to take my
rock I could move my rook in this
position but I have a better move and I
want to see if you can find it what's
the best move here for black
excellent rookie for not only you
stopped his threat you basically blocked
his queen now on f3 the queen is going
to be out of the game and now I'm also
attacking the pawn on a four it's a very
strong move rookie for this Bishop is
still hanging if he moves the bishop
then I can take the pawn on f4 so he
took the pawn on c5 I could take his
bishop probably winning also but first I
would like to get my knight into the
game so I take the f4 pawn attacking the
rook on it too
nine plus B seven attacking my rook
now I have many squares to go to but
usually you want to bring the rook to f8
in this kind of positions because King
is protecting the rook in case of a move
rook c8 your rook will be protected now
I place Luke c8 it looks a little bit
scary but actually calculated that I'm
winning this because now looks like he's
going to clean too now I take some
material so I take the rook first with
the check
he takes I take the bishop Queen takes
now I'll put rock clearly up the rook
but this pawn is very dangerous now I'm
going to allow actually to promote this
pawn into a queen but I will win his
rook so in fact it's going to have two
Queens on the board so what's the best
move here for black because he's
threatening now to play b8 Queen
Queen a6 you have to be very careful
because he could hi Queen 86 you could
actually take on a faith he could take
on a faith and play b8 so I think I have
to play this one because it's my only
move
rook back to e8 because if he captures I
will just take back with the rook
preventing him from playing b8 so now he
has no choice but to play b8 Quinn but
then I take his rook
now he has two Queens on the board but I
have two rooks and a pawn extra pawn
here because I have four pounds and he
has three
in fact now now black is just winning
here so you played Queen b3 check King
h8 another very important factors my
king is very safe two queens are very
strong when they can create threats
against the open king they are very
dangerous but when my king is very safe
like this they're kind of ineffective so
it plays Queen a for trying to win the
pawn on d4 so I play rook f d8 bring my
rook into the game you played a six and
I played d3 and I realize I'm probably
winning here but I definitely didn't
expect him to resign in this position
and this is the first time that my
opponent resigned with two queens on the
board but if we look at this a little
bit more we try to analyze we will see
that C no of course you know Grandmaster
shovel of realized is just completely
lost if you see a chance it would
probably play on okay let's see now I
would like to set up one position for
you and game
okay
you're playing this position with the
white pieces it the same color Bishop
endgame and now white King is under a
check and you need to decide where do
you want to go with this King if you go
to the wrong square you're not going to
win this game and if go to the right
square you're going to win so basically
you need to choose between kinky eight
or King g8 but there is a reason why one
move is winning and another one is a
draw
aha King town center okay anybody else
it's very logical but there is a rule in
the bishop endgame when you see the
opponent let's say if you go here right
then his bishop is going to be on a long
diagonal okay
so then he will go here and we're going
to have a hard time moving this bishop
from this diagonal because if we go
check he goes here the general rule is
if you have a passed pawn and you're
about to Quinn you want to try to drive
his Bishop from the long diagonal to the
short diagonal the short diagonal is
this diagonal here that he can control
to stop you from promoting the pawn if
you keep him on a long diagonal you're
not going to be able to win this game so
that's why in this position the best
move is actually to King g8 now let's
see how we can move this bishop from a
tree from the long diagonal to the short
diagonal first step is to do that there
are few steps you need to make to win
this endgame you're not just going to be
able to win because you have a passed
pawn on a seventh rank because if you
just Queen this pawn he is you're going
to sacrifice the bishop it will be a
draw now how can you move this bishop
from a3 let's see if you can find the
first step how can we do that
well you have to make sure you protect
your palm yeah I'll stick it so you have
to protect upon bishops it is very good
so let's say I play this one Bishop c3 I
go Bishop III now what do we do to move
the bishop from this diagonal
Bishop g7 correct bishop before
- perfect aha so now we move the bishop
from the diagonal because if he if he's
going to exchange you're going to take
and then you're going to step any
direction and promote the pond then
you're going to check mated with the
Queen so he has to move the bishop and
he's going to go to d2 because just in
case he cannot get on the long diagonal
he wants to put the bishop on a short
diagonal so now you move the bishop back
and threatening to Quinn
once your queen you're going to win the
game you can
checkmate him easily so he has to go
Bishop h6 now when the bishop is on a
short diagonal he has less scores to go
to to to go and also to control the f8
square now you can do something with
this Bishop to deflect him away so you
can promote this pawn into a queen
attack with the bishop from here right
if he takes turn you bro promote the
pawn you can win this easily with the
king and queen versus a bishop so he has
to play the only movies Bishop g7 and
now what is the winning move here the
move after which block is going to
resign there are probably a few ways to
win but this one will probably end the
game immediately
yes
absolutely that that wins to the Bishop
d2 wins - but something a little bit
better it's it's a winning but putting
into a complete socks on
- okay Bishop g5 now complete looks
among four black now Bishop cannot move
any square now we're going to take and
promote King cannot move anywhere
because you take the bishop so now he
has to take six of our normal four black
now you run out of moves here so he's
going to take your Bishop gonna take the
bishop and promote the pawn into a win
okay so the rule very important rule to
know in the same color Bishop endgame
that you always want to drive the bishop
from the long diagonal to the short
diagonal there many examples I can show
you where you do this and you win the
game but if you will play King g8 here
see the reason this is not helping you
because you're not controlling any
squares on the short diagonal I mean
you're controlling the f8 but you're not
controlling the g7 square but when you
play King g8 you control the square on a
diagonal two squares you control with
the King and the third one you're going
to control with the bishop so that's why
you can win this game okay okay now I'm
going to set up another position it's
more difficult than this one okay it's a
very important position and you'll see
that it's same type of idea but it's
it's a little bit more difficult to win
because black has more defensive ideas
here now in this position it's similar
to the previous example but the only
thing is black has excellent extra
defense here so here white is going to
win this game if it plays the right way
but right now you cannot promote this
pawn because he will take the bishop the
first step what is the first step that
we learn from the previous example short
- what's where is the short diagonal
here
now a short diagonal that he can control
the BH square okay that's a short
diagonal this is the long diagonal right
inside the two diagonals that he can use
to control the BH square if you just
drive the bishop away from the diagonal
you're going to win this game because
you're going to promote the pawn even if
you lose your bishop you promote a pawn
into a queen you're going to win so
let's try to see how we can try to do
that how can we drive the bishop from
the long diagonal to the short diagonal
is this is going to be really short
diagonal because only two squares or
just one square here on a cèlle so
what's the first step in this position
for white
okay move the bishop where where can we
move this bishop that's we have to move
the bishop yes try to use the same way
you did in the previous example remember
to move the bishop from a long diagonal
you have to put your bishop to the same
diagonal so you have to bring this
bishop to h4 let's say I played this one
this is not the best defense I will show
you the best defense after this line so
we go here right so we bring the bishop
to the long diagonal correct that's the
only way to do it
you have to use always have to look at
the whole squares you know the entire
board because it's the only way you can
bring this bishop to the long diagonal
now you go here in order to move the
bishop from the long diagonal you have
to put your own Bishop on that diagonal
so now he moves the bishop we move the
bishop back now we're threatening to
Queen it cannot come here to this
diagonal because we take so it goes back
here and now now if it goes here now
we're just going to deflect the bishop
with bishop g1 and white wins because he
takes the bishop you Quinn did we pawn
you cannot go here because you just take
but now as I mentioned there is a better
defense here when you play Bishop age
for you are planning to go Bishop c7 and
Bishop a7 here he's going to realize
that so he's going to play King b6 so
when you play Bishop f2 check in the
working a6 and he's not going to allow
you to get your Bishop to the long
diagonal now you're going to win this
game by gaining a tempo very valuable
tempo
see that's the original position if you
reach this position with block to play
you can win this
so that's why we're going to try to do
that here after we go hit after we go he
goes king b6 now what can we do here to
gain that one tempo we want this bishop
to be on a different square when we
reach the original position we want this
bishop to be on g3 or different square
well if you go here then I'm not going
to take I'm going to go here yeah I'm on
a long diagonal so you can really
deflect me away by just attacking me
because I'm just I have too many squares
to go to be the bishop I will stay on
this diagonal okay so we go back here I
can't go I can't go to here right
because he will just take me so this is
not going to work so I go back to c5 now
he can move the King because once he
moves the King then I can go Bishop a
seven let's say if he comes here to
attack my bishop I go here then I win
because of putting my bishop to the long
diagonal so now he moves the bishop now
he's forced to move the bishop now I go
Bishop back here now I'm threatening to
go Bishop d8 and Bishop c7 now he needs
to stop that threat so he's going to go
back with the king to b6 and now you're
going to go check did you realize that
we reach the same position that I set it
up for you the only one difference is
bishop is now on g3 and that's what
difference it makes a big change here
you will win now because you gained a
temple
because now you're going to be able to
get your bishop to the long diagonal
because you can use that temple which
temple I'm talking about
again we want to bring the bishop to be
a TIA excellent
Bishop h4 so we do the same idea but we
gain a temple because now he needs to
move the bishop he doesn't have time to
play King b6 King a6 and he cannot take
the bishop because you Quinn
so he has to play he has to move the
bishop and then what do you do
Bishop f2 see now we're going to get
there we're going to get to a 7 and b8
so because he can't do anything he has
to go Bishop f4 space 7 it should be 8
fish per for threatening to Queen Bishop
a 7
Bishop e3 white wins so that one temple
with the you know Bishop on h2 it's more
difficult to win but once you force the
bishop on g3 let's do this again one
more time so you can see how this works
so you start with bish page for
threatening to go Bishop f2 and Bishop
a7 so he has to bring his King to a6
this is the best defense
you check k a6 Bishop see yeah this is
not going to help so we're going to go
Bishop c5
now I place a g3 so now we go back with
a bishop because we want to go Bishop
did b7 just covered the long diagonal so
he cannot allow us to do that because
now we just play here bishop here
just be sure c7 and after the exchange
of the bishops you promote upon so he
has to play King b6 now you play Czech
seer regional position but the bishop is
on g3 not on h2 and that gives us the
extra tempo
Bishop h4 we attack the bishop he cannot
capture because we Quinn so he has to go
back black ink because now it's under a
check if if it doesn't go there then as
the errors are showing we bring the
bishop here and then he can no longer
stay on this diagonal and we promote
upon into a queen so he needs to bring
the King back to c6 to stop that idea
but the King cannot be in two places at
the same time so that's why now he has
to do that and now we gain this tempo
bh4 and you will win the game and the
final idea you put them on the short
diagonal and deflect by sacrificing your
bishop excellent any questions about
this Bishop endgame same color Bishop
endgame most important idea to remember
is that you want to drive the bishop
from the long diagonal to the short
diagonal and then try to deflect it
there are more endgame positions and
next week I will be here we will work on
some more and game positions like this
ok ok thank you all for coming
you
you